okay
let's close it
okay
once you have developed a system an
examination of the mouth can be done
quickly
and should be a part of your routine
examination of patients
from a general health standpoint an oral
examination will help you detect
infections that may contribute to
systemic diseases
like subacute bacterial endocarditis
or conversely there may be oral
manifestations of systemic diseases
in either case your general treatment
plan would be influenced
in addition the advanced oral cancer
like this one
is difficult to manage and routine
examination
can result in earlier diagnosis
i'll now run through a routine oral
examination for you
i'll also show you some oral cancers in
their early stages
good light is important a headlamp is
preferable
a flashlight does not furnish adequate
light also it leaves you with only one
hand free
you won't need any additional equipment
other than what is ordinarily in your
office
it's important to take a history
if there are symptoms explore them fully
before proceeding with the examination
a convenient first step is inspection of
the skin of the head and neck
check all skin lesions closely
pigmented lesions especially should be
carefully evaluated
if your patient wears a denture remove
it before you examine the mouth
these should be checked ill-fitting
dentures are a frequent cause of
traumatic lesions
occasionally a denture sore may be
malignant
the chronic denture sore in this
patient's upper gum was malignant
it's handy to begin with the lips
this innocent appearing abnormality
commonly called leukoplakia
actually is an invasive carcinoma
while the lip is retracted inspect the
anterior teeth for dental caries
the gum should be inspected for
abnormalities
next the buccal mucosa and stenson's
duct
if the patient is a pipe smoker you may
discover this kind of leukoplakia
this lesion was carcinoma in situ
note any pathologic changes of the
posterior teeth and gums
the roof of the mouth should be
systematically inspected
innocent appearing lesions may be
serious a cytologic smear from this red
area revealed suspicious cells
and the biopsy report was carcinoma
next examination of the soft palate
uvula
posterior pharyngeal wall and tonsils
the tongue is depressed to inspect the
posterior pharyngeal wall
and then retracted to look at the
tonsils and tonsiller pillars
also the posterior floor of the mouth
lower teeth and gum can be examined at
this time
now we'll examine the ventral surface of
the tongue the anterior floor of mouth
and the gums of the lower front teeth
the dorsal and lateral surface of the
tongue can be examined by gripping it
with a piece of gauze
let's take out your time
let me show you two different tongue
cancers
this small white lesion was found during
a routine examination
of a 41 year old female
a smear revealed suspicious cells and
the biopsy report was carcinoma
this small ulcer was found in a 26 year
old male
with a history of syphilis cytology was
positive
and the biopsy report was carcinoma
it's advisable to palpate the entire
mouth
the neck should be examined routinely
any palpable lymph nodes
may represent metastatic disease
we're basically interested in helping
you detect oral cancers
preferably in their earliest stage
if there's any uncertainty about any
abnormality a referral may be in order
now i'd like to present the chief of the
public health service
cancer control program dr william ross
we're faced with a number of problems in
our struggle to control
oral cancer relatively it has a low
incidence
in addition there is a high incidence of
non-malignant lesions in the mouth
yet our projects and those of the
veterans administration
all of which were conducted in large
medical centers by competent staffs
revealed that over twenty percent of all
lesions found were unsuspected
the unsuspected did not have the typical
signs and symptoms of cancer
they were biopsied only because
cytologic specimens were taken
and abnormal cells were found most oral
lesions you will see in your patients
will be non-malignant but unless you
actively try to reach a diagnosis for
all lesions
the cancers will remain undetected until
they are far advanced
the associated benefits of oral
examinations are many
first the discovery of pre-malignant
lesions
second the discovery of other systemic
conditions
and finally an increased awareness of
the problems of dental and oral hygiene
as physicians you have a responsibility
for the total health of your patients
your cooperation in an oral examination
program
is essential
you